[Music]
what is up reject nations John Humphrey
over here it's greg alba over here and
we've got a special little video today
we had a visitor this past friday the
piggy man from American Horror Story
season six not the one from season one
different character came by the
apartment
[Music]
and dropped off this mysterious chest
says Roanoke on it and we're gonna open
it for you guys today I haven't told
that we are the first people to get our
hands on one of these there's something
inside from the actual sets I have no
idea yeah we watched Roanoke two weeks
ago actually and I really liked that
season mixed responses on it but I
really enjoyed the hell out of that
season a lot and we're not just saying
that yeah
the first half was good but the second
half I thought was fantastic
yeah well this scary yeah I've heard
like the last like there's like three
episodes or I was like I'm really long
the Ejim I'm actually scared normally
not like scared during a man I'm really
just fascinated so I'm pretty excited to
see what's in the box and it's a season
that really does remind you the rewards
of sticking with the season yeah by the
time I got to the end I was like ah yeah
yeah definitely so I'm gonna start by
unlatching this a little nervous all
right
hard parts done lift the lid oh I'm not
gonna show you guys first I'm gonna pull
things out one it is yeah all right
enclosed and closed there's a note the
blood moon rises surrender thy soul you
have been chosen by the last Colony of
Roanoke oh I never get chosen for
anything I know me neither of number one
I'm so excited I'm so glad to be part of
the Roanoke raffle let's see what's in
here up it's covered in dirt all OH we
got a DV we got a blur oh yeah
oh yeah that is dirty that is dirty what
is that into really dirty they went all
out oh they went wrong I would love it
if I open the actual disk there's dirt
on the dirt inside of the disk
oh great this is cool others like
special features on here and stuff Oh
hundred ninety nine minutes that's what
we watched it in week three hundred
ninety nine minutes yeah the Paley
Center Q&A with the creative team on
here this is really cool because we
bought it off of Amazon and we could
only stream it if we have the Amazon app
working so it's cool to actually have a
good blu-ray of this I'm holding on to
this one because I bought the Amazon one
so I get to keep this one is I'm gonna
keep this one that's fair
only fair it's fair that's fair it's the
way it works i brokered this deal hey
this is pretty cool you ready right
you're looking at it there's no some Oh
lookie here like the freaky hanging
would prob that's usually the first sign
if you guys haven't seen the season yet
that's the first sign of Roanoke
whenever something terrible is about to
go down you see a messed up he would
nail do another piece of wood that looks
roughly like a business no
authentication don't look at them look
inside the bottom yeah I want you guys
to know oh yeah and the show it rains
teeth sometimes teeth oh this is like
real I wish I could show you guys up
close but looky there there's some teeth
for you yeah we'll get some dental
hygiene there's usually a bunch of these
that appear showing that the Colony of
Roanoke is coming for you you guys can't
see this but there is so much dirt
there's a lot a cert inside of this box
it's like real authentic dirt it's not
like prop dirt I didn't leave the
blu-ray in here so that nothing bad
happens yeah I think I've mixed some of
the teeth into the soil or shoot I'll
dig through here and find them again
dude we can plant some some trees or so
knowing John and I we're never gonna get
rid of the dirt this is not our style
I think that's the only thing that might
be an actual prop this was custom made
this box provided us from Fox Home
Entertainment and it's a customized box
to Fox and when they showed up with it I
was like this is pretty cool I thought
is this gonna be like cool American
Horror Story things but they kept this
authentic you have to be like an actual
fan of the show to really appreciate
this stuff yeah and if you haven't seen
the show I'm telling you guys it's out
on blu-ray right now and
I'm happy we have a copy of it yeah me
too this was one of the more gripping
seasons yeah I jumped on in recent times
we watch like the first five episodes in
one day at a time and then the last five
we were like this was so good once we
got to watch the whole thing in one
night we were it's like 3:00 in the
morning we started at like 8:00 we're
just gonna go for it
be sure to follow at Fox home and like
this hashtag aah aah
that's a HS Rowan oh yeah Big Ups to
them for sending this over I'm gonna put
this somewhere prominent and display it
for please Steve and if you guys don't
know what Roanoke is just go to North
Carolina and find the colony where they
are very welcoming and inviting and not
in Virginia history Croatoan all right
well hey guys you can subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
Bell perhaps maybe find out if there's a
new video or not who cares
he's the greg alba on twitter and
instagram i am dad John Humphrey and as
always hey check out our patreon patreon
comm slash the real rejects we've got a
lot of exclusive content pics videos
reactions will write you a letter just
come check it out much love till next
time
pace